new details emerge in the fbi
investigation into trump campaign
members and they are damning for the fbi
violence continues in louisville as the
media refused to look at the facts
surrounding brianna taylor's death
and trump reiterates he won't concede
the election if he suspects voter fraud
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do stop
that keep yourself
safe at expressvpn.com now remember you
got to tune in to a special presidential
debate edition of daily wire backstage
tuesday september 29th at 5 45 pm
pacific
8 45 pm eastern we are going to watch
the rock soccer robots
will joe biden make it out of there
without stumbling physically
will president trump simply start
babbling nonsensically who the hell
knows
it's going to be wild but we're going to
be there to cover it with you and suffer
every painful moment go check us out
daily wire backstage tuesday september
29th 5 45
at pm at pacific 8 45 pm eastern time
and i'll have to suffer through being in
a
room with knolls okay before we get
started gotta remind you about one quick
thing
your underwear okay so i know now you're
thinking about your underwear and you're
thinking yeah the band is stretchy and
yeah it's old and it's falling apart but
do i need better underwear the answer is
you
absolutely need better underwear i mean
you're going to be spending all day in
those underwear this is why i recommend
tommy john's cool cotton underwear for
men and women it is made from premium
natural pima cotton for enhanced airflow
keeping you cooler and more comfortable
than regular cotton
tommy john's breathable lightweight
moisture wicking fabric has four times
the stretch
of competing bands so it moves with you
rather than bunching up
whether you're on the hunt for lounge
pants lazy day joggers are the softest
zoom ready t's and polos you've ever
worn
tommy john has you covered as well i
mean when it comes to loungewear they do
it the best their underwear alone have
sold over 96
four-star plus reviews and over 11
million pairs that sold that's a lot of
underwear there is no reason not to try
tommy john because if you don't love the
first pair you get a full refund with
the best pair you'll ever wear or it's
free
guaranteed i mean that is a solid deal
tommy john no adjustment needed right
now
get a really solid deal go to
tommyjohn.com get 20 off your first
order with code ben
codebend tommyjohn.com it is great for
men it is great for women i enjoy tommy
john products so does my wife
check out tommyjohn.com get 20 off your
first order
with code ben c site for details all
righty so
the the the whole russia gate scandal
the the
attempt by members of the intelligence
community to target people who are
members of the trump campaign
and do so on the basis of
extraordinarily thin evidence this is
particularly true with for example
carter page who is targeted on the basis
of essentially
no evidence other than weird allegations
made in the steel
dossier has been an ongoing scandal for
a while and i'll be honest with you it
was so complex
and so confusing and so speculative at
the beginning that didn't cover it i
wasn't the first person to cover it
the person who i think covered it the
best is probably dan bongino by the way
best wishes to dan he just announced
that he uh has some sort of neck tumor
and so we obviously are all praying for
him
dan covered this at length in his book
spygate he's been covering it on a show
but it is now perfectly obvious that
there were members of the intelligence
community who simply wanted to see the
trump campaign targeted that ranged from
obviously peter strzok and lisa page to
possibly james comey
who was basically preventing information
from being disseminated through the
proper channels he was not informing
the incoming trump administration of
suspicions about members
of the trump campaign he was going above
and beyond the law in order to target
michael flynn
so much so that now attorney general
william barr has decided not to
prosecute
michael flynn well now we have more
evidence that members of the
intelligence community were perverting
the system
in order to go after members of the
trump campaign yesterday catherine
herridge over at cbs reported
that according to the durham report john
durham is a
is an attorney paid for by the federal
government who is going through
all of the sort of roots of the
russiagate investigation
trying to figure out where all this came
from was their malfeasance who performed
the malfeasance
well according to that durham report new
information emerging
the primary subsource for the steele
dossier was deemed a possible national
security threat
and the subject of a 2009 fbi counter
intelligence probe
okay so you have to remember the actual
story here the actual story here
is that the steele dossier was used as
the predicate it was used as the basis
for the fisa warrant against carter page
it was used as sort of the central piece
of evidence in pursuit of members of the
trump campaign
because there was this compendium of
nonsense and maybe not nonsense that was
being disseminated throughout the
federal government it was compiled
by a firm connected with hillary clinton
it was then laundered basically
to the fbi and the fbi picked it up and
started their investigation and used
this heavily in their investigation
in the fisa warrants for carter page but
also in sort of other areas
of the investigation well now catherine
harris is reporting that by december
2016 everybody knew that the steele
dossier was not only crap it was
probably
deliberate disinformation because the
person who is the
chief source for the steele dossier was
deemed a possible national security
threat
and the subject of 2009 fbi
counterintelligence probe
according to new records those facts
were known to the crossfire hurricane
team
as of december 2016. that did not stop
the dissemination of the steele dossier
remember that buzzfeed reported on the
steele dossier in january of 2017
specifically because they said that the
president of the united states had been
presented information about the steele
dossier but we now know that the intel
community knew by december 2016
that the entire sort of primary basis
for the steele dossier was nonsense so
there's always been a suspicion
that the way the buzzfeed and the media
were reporting on the steele dossier
which had been floating around ready to
went to john mccain among other people
had been floating around out there in
washington dc
that the the basic hook upon which the
media
decided to rely in order to report all
of the garbage in the steel dossier was
this report
that trump had been informed about the
steel dossier well now it's news worthy
and now we get to report it there's only
one problem
why was the intel community even
bringing this thing up to trump why were
they using it as the basis for the fisa
warrant for carter page
i mean these documents are really really
damning again it shows
that the primary subsource was possibly
a russian spy
according to the document there's an
overview of the counterintelligence
investigation
of christopher steele's primary
subsource between may 2009 and march
2011 the fbi maintained an investigation
into the individual
who later would be identified as
christopher steele's primary sub source
the fbi commenced this investigation
based on information by the fbi
indicating
that the primary subsource may be a
threat to national security
specifically the fbi reported receiving
received reporting indicating a research
fellow for an influential foreign policy
advisor in the obama administration
was at a work-related event in late 2008
with a co-worker when they were
approached by another employee of the
think tank
the employee reportedly indicated that
if the two individuals at the table
did get a job in the government and had
access to classified information and
wanted to make a little extra money
the employee knew some people to whom
they could speak
the co-worker did express suspicion of
the employee and had questioned the
possibility the employee might actually
be
a russian spy in december 2016 the fbi's
crossfire hurricane investigation
identified the employee as christopher
steele's primary
subsource so in other words the
intelligence community knew full well
that this guy was full of crap and then
they proceeded to use this
as the basis for launching the
investigation into carter page
among others according to this
documentation
in september 2006 the primary subsource
was in contact with a known
russian intelligence officer in 2005 the
subsource was making contact with the
washington dc based russian officer
one individual indicated the primary
subsource was not anti-american but
wanted to return to russia one day
another described the primary subsources
pro-russia
indicated that he or she always
interjected russian opinions during
foreign policy discussions
so the timeline of december 2016 is when
they knew
that this got that basically the seal
dossier was nonsense they promulgated it
anyway they announced it to trump and
then all of a sudden it finds its way
into the press
all of which suggest that this was an
attempt to subvert the incoming trump
administration at the very very least
and now there are text messages that
have been emerging from the fbi
detailing
the quote-unquote internal furor over
the handling of the crossfire hurricane
investigation is according to the
federalist shaun davis and molly
hemingway reporting
fbi agents tacked by fired former
director james comey to take down donald
trump during and after the 2016 election
were so concerned about the agency's
potentially illegal behavior that they
purchased liability
insurance to protect themselves less
than two weeks before trump was
inaugurated president
previously hidden fbi text messages show
the explosive new communications and
internal fbi notes were disclosed in
federal court filings today from sydney
powell the attorney who heads michael
flynn's legal defense team
we all went and purchased professional
liability insurance one agent texted on
january 10 2017
the same day cnn leaked details that
then president-elect trump had been
briefed by comey about the bogus
christopher steele dossier
that briefing of trump was used as a
pretext to legitimize the debunked
dossier which was funded by the dnc and
the clinton campaign and compiled by a
foreign intelligence officer who was
working for a sanctioned russian
oligarch
holy crap an agent responded all the
analysts too yep the first agent said
all the folks at the agency as well
can i ask for the most who are the most
likely litigators an agent responded as
far as potentially sueno
haha who knows i think the concern when
we got it was that there was a big leak
at doj and the new york times among
others
was going to appease while the names of
the agents responsible for the texts are
redacted the legal filing from powell
quoting communications from the doj
states
the latest document production included
handwritten news notes and texts from
peter strzok who let up
all of these investigations andrew
mccabe lisa page an fbi analyst who
worked on the fbi's investigation of
flynn
agents also said they were worried about
how a new attorney general might view
the actions taken against trump during
the investigation
the new ag might have some questions
then we all get screwed one agent wrote
fbi agents also discussed how the
investigation's leadership was consumed
with conspiracy theories rather than
evidence
i'm telling you man if this thing ever
gets foied they're going to be some
tough questions asked one agent wrote
and a great deal of those will be
related to brian
having a scope way outside the
boundaries of logic
redacted so they took out the name is
one of the worst offenders of the rabbit
holes in conspiracy theories
the guy traveled with that guy who put
down the third guy as his visa sponsor
third guy lives near a navy base
therefore several texts show the order
to close the criminal investigation
against michael flynn came as early as
november 8 2016 the same day as the 2016
presidential election
it was later reopened in early january
of 2017 on the thin
read that it was a logan act violation
for mike flynn to be talking with the
russians when in fact it was not
we have some loose ends to tie up we all
need to meet to discuss what to do with
each case
one agent texted referring to in the
operation called crossfire raiser which
was the fbi's code name for the
investigation of michael flynn
the news the new disclosures made by the
doj also show the fbi
used so-called national security letters
to spy on michael flynn's finances
unlike traditional subpoenas which do
require judicial review and approval
before authorities can seize an innocent
person's property and information
nsls are never independently reviewed by
courts
one of the agents noted in a text
message that these particular
form of surveillance were being used
were just being used as a pretext by the
fbi leadership to buy time to find
dirt on flynn after the first
investigation of him yielded no
derogatory information the decision to
finalize
the decision to nsl finances for
razer bought him time one agent said two
weeks after the initial order to shut
down the anti-flame case
what do we expect to get from an nsl and
agent text in on december 5th 2016 we
put out traces tripwires to community
nothing bingo another agent responded so
what's an nsl going to do no content
haha this is a nightmare an agent said
so a lot of the agents were deeply
suspicious that all of this was
basically bullcrap and as it turns out
it was in fact bullcrap
and these agents were were deeply upset
at the fact that the agency was now
being used
as a way to launch our anti-trump intel
into the public
or target president trump
on january 15th on january 5th they
could not believe
that the intel report was going to stay
open razer is going to stay open an
agent wrote on january 5th
yep another fbi agent responded crimes
report being drafted
f the first agent wrote back what's the
word on how the obama briefing went one
agent asked referring to a january 5th
meeting between james comey
and barack obama don't know but people
here are scrambling for information to
support certain things it's a mad house
an fbi agent responded
jesus an agent wrote back trump was
right still not put together why do we
do this to ourselves what is wrong with
these people
so all of this is obviously deeply
disturbing and undermines fundamental
institutions of the american republic
kimberly strassel has a good threat on
this over at the wall street journal she
says
breaking per catherine herridge and
extraordinary so christopher steele's
main source for the dossier he was the
subject of a nearly two year long
fbi counselor intel investigation under
suspicion of being a russian spy and a
threat to national security
early in the obama administration the
subsource reportedly attempted to
recruit two individuals connected to an
influential foreign policy adviser to
obama
said if they got jobs in the
administration and access to classified
info he could help them make a little
money
fbi says he had previous contact with
the russian embassy and russian
intelligence officers
thanks to paul sperry we know the name
of this subsource and that he for a
period at this time
was a was at brookings a democratic
think tank here's the real kicker the
fbi knew about this prior ci
investigation into the source
in december of 2016. it knew it was
relying on information from a suspected
russian spy
the same fbi said to be concerned about
russian interference in the election was
using information from a suspected
russian spy to probe a presidential
campaign
the same fbi claiming carter page was a
russian agent was making that case based
on info
from a suspected russian agent most
importantly it never told the fisa court
about
this ci investigation withheld that
information it continued re-upping its
applications to surveil carter page on
the campaign
it vouched for information supplied by a
suspected russian agent the name of the
subsource the realization of the fbi's
prior suspicions should have ended the
entire probe instead
the fbi doubled down hid things from the
court and kept going this again raises
urgent need to know
who knew what and when and people wonder
why john durham is looking into all of
this
also extra credit question wasn't it
mueller's job to find sources of russian
disinformation how do you miss the guy
potentially feeding it directly to the
fbi
and the the fact that this went as far
as it did
is an astonishing breach of the nation's
ability to trust
its intelligence community and i've been
very skeptical of a lot of the
criticisms made of the intelligence
community i didn't like it when
president trump
talked badly of the intelligence
community i thought that he painted with
too broad a brush at the very least
but it is perfectly obvious there were
actors inside the fbi who were
engaged in bad activity in order to
target
president trump and his campaign it is
perfectly obvious at this point that
that was what was going on and i think
we're going to find out some more
damning info
as the durham investigation makes its
way forward through the doj
okay in just a second we're going to get
to the continuation of violence
across the country actually over the
death of brianna taylor
and the exoneration of the officers in
that case except for one officer who is
charged with wanton
discharge of a firearm we'll get to that
in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you
definitely definitely need to have the
best employees
working for you let's say you have a
wonderful new producer
let's call rebecca and let's say she's
just terrific there's only one problem
she brings up topics to talk about
about 35 seconds before the show which
is not ideal because
usually you need more than 35 seconds to
research the topics in every way she's
wonderful except for that way so let's
say that you need another employee to do
it correctly
well then you would need to check out
zip recruiter zip recruiter will send
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job sites but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology ziprecruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and then actively invites
them to apply to your job
zip recruiter makes hiring efficient and
effective with features like screening
questions to filter candidates and an
all-in-one dashboard where you can
review and rate your candidates
ziprecruiter in fact is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within
the very first day right now to try zip
recruiter for free
my listeners can go to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire this is great if you are an
employee looking for an employer
or the other way around at
ziprecruiter.com d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
try zip recruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire's zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire already so
the the chaos continued across the
country
every time there is a controversial race
case in which the media completely
ignore the underlying facts in order to
achieve
what they want to achieve which is
further racial conflagration further
racial tension this stuff breaks out
every single time and it's going to
continue this way i do not think it's
going to end if joe biden becomes
president
because who exactly is going to be
sanguine about the octogenarian
the oxygenarian barely awake
long-time senator who did nothing making
sure that all racial tensions in the
country are quelled
also the the democratic party and the
media have set a goal that is un
uninten obtainable it is just not there
it's not you can't get to it
that goal is the end of all racism
whatsoever
and not just the goal to end all racism
but the goal to end
all situations in which racism could
possibly be attributed to the situation
even if there's no racism evident from
the situation
there's still no evidence that number
one brianna taylor was shot on purpose
number two that brianna taylor was shot
because she was black
there's no evidence this had anything to
do with racism it doesn't matter it's
seen
as an element of the racist justice
system the racist policing
system the predictable result of all of
this is the
insanity that we have been seeing in our
cities and again i think that you are
going to see
such flight from urban centers i think
it's going to be as bad
as it was in the 1970s when the crime
rates really really began to spike and
it's because of incidents like this so
we currently live in los angeles not for
long and one of the reasons
that we do not want to live in los
angeles is because of incidents like
this so
yesterday down in hollywood last night
there were protests over
brianna taylor about 350 people
apparently showed up at these protests
and cars were attempting to get through
because these are public streets there
are no
permits taken out for these protests you
know you can see the spray paints on the
sidewalks and
and in the middle of the street and all
this you can see a huge crowd of people
who are gathered in the middle of the
street again
protesting in the middle of a pandemic
without any permit or anything else but
you know this is all good because we
need
this moment of racial reckoning as joe
biden has suggested and what you'll see
is a person in a white priest simply
trying to get through this is obviously
not somebody who's attempting to harm
members of the crowd
this is a person who's probably trying
to get home okay this is not somebody
who's ramming their car deliberately
into protesters or anything like this
you can see they're driving very very
slowly
just trying to get through they're
driving maybe five miles an hour
really really slowly and then once they
get through then they take off in the
car right then they then they start
hitting the gas they haven't hit anybody
the crowd starts chasing them
and then you'll see a these helicopter
footage you'll see
a truck filled with looters who
cut the guy off pretty much boxed in
they box him in
a mustang approaches from behind and he
tries to back up the mustang blocks
and they start beating the crap out of
this person somebody reaches through the
driver's side window
apparently grabbing the steering wheel
people start taking flagpoles
and bicycles and smashing windows
somebody smash it takes a skateboard and
smashes the front windshield of the car
and then the prius takes off down the
street in case the prius didn't injure
anybody these people were trying to harm
the driver inside they're trying to beat
the crap out of the car for the great
sin of the person trying to get home
so what ends up happening the police
pull the driver over
and force the driver to get out of his
car with his hands raised
like this is why people are going to
leave cities because it turns out that
when you refuse to allow the police to
enforce the law
you know how you could have enforced the
law here large gatherings in the middle
of a pandemic without a public permit
should not be allowed how is it that you
can lock i'm not kidding you
tens of millions of people across the
country in their homes during a lockdown
but the minute there's a protest in the
street of 350 people in la
you're not allowed to break up the
protest even as they take over public
property and threaten people's lives and
property
how how and the answer is because you
back the movement because you're kind of
okay with what's going on
that is the only reason because if you
weren't okay with what was going on you
would stop
it meanwhile louisville turned into a
hotbed last night again andy noe was on
the ground in louisville
and he got some tape of people
performing acts of looting again
in louisville so that was just wonderful
there was also my friend amy horowitz
friends of the show
ami horowitz showed up in louisville and
he was shouted at and uh
and he was intimidated into putting down
his camera these are all folks who care
deeply about civil rights to the point
where they tell you literally are not
allowed to tape them in a public place
as they commit act of violence the good
news is that our democratic leadership
is really talking these things down i
mean they're really trying to calm the
waters here so kamala harris the vice
presidential candidate who's gone
about as missing as it is possible for a
vp candidate to go she along with biden
are just hiding in the bunker so biden
i believe called another lid today i
believe which means that he has now been
absent from the campaign trail like 10
of the last 13 days
and the meteor like oh he's probably
prepping for debate it doesn't take 13
days to prep for a debate
and um he's not prepping for debate he's
just hiding in the basement hoping that
donald trump's innate
unpopularity with the american people
lets joe biden sort of coast into office
without having to get off his gurney in
any case kamala harris tweeted out
black americans don't need to be
reminded that inequity runs deep in our
country
it's a painful reality every day we will
only begin to fully heal when our nation
addresses the systemic racism in our
laws
policies and institutions joe biden and
i have a plan to do just that no you
don't
no you don't and she tweeted out keep
speaking brianna taylor's name
okay again brianna taylor was the victim
of a tragedy
brianna taylor was not the victim of a
crime
end of story when you say keep saying
brianna taylor's name uh
what exactly about saying brianna
taylor's name is going to be effective
in effectuating change that will be
useful
it's one thing if you're talking about
revising some of the laws regarding no
knock warrants although in this
particular case if they'd actually
effectuated their knock warrant brianna
taylor might well be alive
the problem was that they knocked and
then they announced themselves and then
that allowed
her boyfriend walker to get up out of
bed grab a gun and then shoot at the
door which is what caused
the entire crossfire situation to happen
but beyond that if if you're talking
about the
the horrors of the brianna taylor
situation the suggestion tacitly and
implicitly there
is that the police were in the wrong and
that the police should have been
prosecuted
in the killing of brianna taylor which
again there is no legal evidence to back
this idea
it does not mesh with reality it simply
does not it has not for months
everybody who has studied this case and
is honest about it knows that
there are certain cases where charges
are warranted ahmed are very there are
cases where certain charges are not
warranted brianna taylor is one of those
cases
hey but when she says that we have a
plan to end systemic racism no you don't
the entire use of the term systemic
racism
means that there is no plan there is no
way to end systemic racism
except to tear down systems that's why
the term systemic racism includes
the word systemic if your plan to end
systemic racism does not include tearing
down systems it in fact
is about you being elected in order to
run those systems then you're not ending
systemic racism you are perpetuating
systemic racism
and herein lies the problem as i've been
pointing out for a long time here
the chief proponents of so-called
institutional or systemic racism suggest
that the way you can tell systemic or
institutional racism exists
is by disparate impact is by looking at
the outcome of a particular law
and if it does not affect all
communities equally statistically
speaking it is a racist law and must be
ended
or it's a racist system and must be torn
down well once you say systemic racism
and then you say i have a plan to end it
unless you are tearing down the system
you do not have a plan to end it you
want to be part of the system
you are part of the problem you're
upholding the system you're serving the
system
this is why it is not a leap from black
lives matter movement
systemic racism arguments to defund the
police because
reforming the police is not in the cars
you're still reforming a system
that is fundamentally based on slave
catching according to people like
ta-nehisi coates so it does not matter
whether you want to correct small ills
small ills aren't the problem the entire
system is to blame when kamala harris
says systemic races and what she means
is i'm speaking your language but i'm
not going to actually do what i say i'm
going to do
i'm just going to hold out there the
prospect that you're going to be able to
tear down the system if you elect people
like me
it's truly radical and it's truly ugly
then of course you have kamala harris
saying violence isn't the answer
and so she tweeted that out last night
as well she said
that um violence is an issue this is
what she tweeted
she said joe biden and i are keeping the
police officers who were shot in
louisville
in our hearts wishing them a swift and
speedy recovery violence is not the
answer we must find a way to express our
grief anger and demands in ways that
reflect the world we wish to see
okay two thoughts that are not really
easily held at the same time thought
number one the entire system is racist
thought number two attempts to destroy
the system
through use of violence are bad okay
especially when your alternative is what
you're gonna vote for these long-time
politicians including this former
prosecutor kamal harris
you can't have it both ways if the
system is worthy of being torn down is
worthy of being torn down and that means
the people who serve the system are the
bad guys you can't say all cops are good
people or most cops are good people but
really they are brown shirted
servants of a systemically racist system
that argument does not wash and i think
people inherently know that argument
doesn't watch which is why you are
seeing
all this violence in the streets and
meanwhile as we will see the trump
administration is taking
a different attack we'll get to that in
just one second first
let me ask you something what if there
was someone out there who kept the log
of every single thing you did every
minute of the day
i'm not talking about sting i'm not
talking about santa claus i'm not
talking about god i'm talking
about your isp your isp is keeping track
of everything that you do because they
want to monetize everything you do
online
your internet your internet provider
like atnc or comcast is allowed to store
logs of every website you've ever
visited they can legally sell the data
to anyone which is why i always use
expressvpn
expressvpn reroutes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your internet provider can't see or
log what you do online
now some of you might be wondering well
if i'm rooting all my data through a vpn
doesn't that mean that the vpn can see
what i'm doing and log my data instead
you're right to ask this question this
is an excellent question but here's the
good news
expressvpn uses trusted server
technology
they were the first major vpn provider
to engineer all of their vpn services
servers to run in ram which makes it
impossible for their vpn servers to
store any data
including logs of any vpn customer you
don't have to take my or expressvpn's
word for it expressvpn is so confident
in their no logs claim they even had one
of the biggest assurance firms pwc
pricewaterhousecoopers
audit their technology you need to
protect your data expressvpn can help
you do it right now visit expressvpn.com
ben right now find out how you can get
three months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
expressvpn.com ben to learn more
alrighty so the trump administration is
taking a bit of a different attack here
and that tack is that we are going to
defend law enforcement so vice president
mike pence
said this yesterday he said our angle
here is that law enforcement is good
which seems like it should be fairly
inarguable since there is one
tried and true solution to crime and
that is more police officers here is
vice president
pence in the
first three years of this administration
we've been supporting law enforcement at
every level
4 000 police officers funded through the
cops program
we broke records working with state and
local law enforcement
for prosecutions in violent crime and
firearm prosecutions
a violent crime was steadily dropping
from
to historic lows from a time in the
previous eight years that saw violent
crime
on the rise okay he is right
about all of this okay the the trump
administration also sent forth kaylee
mcinning to point out that the media
have been fostering violence now this
does not mean that
if you say things that are bad
ideologically you are responsible for
the violence it does mean that if we are
going to have this argument which we
repeatedly have
about turning up the climate of
hostility in the country and making
excuses for people who do bad things
that is a fair conversation to have i've
said this 1 000 times
i don't blame barack obama for six
police officers being shot in dallas in
2016.
i don't blame bernie sanders for james
hodgkinson shooting
a bunch of people at a congressional
baseball game right bernie sanders
didn't call for that barack obama didn't
call for that
i do blame them for raising the
temperature by suggesting that their
political opponents are the root of all
evil and need to be
destroyed well kaylee mcinerney makes
the same point about
brianna keeler from cnn who's been
making
excuses for the rioters and looters over
on cnn apparently here's kaylee mcinney
cnn's brianna keeler who said i question
the judgment of the kentucky attorney
general saying that mob
justice is not justice we know that this
is very loaded language
that's an appalling statement from
briana keeler at cnn and what is
outrageous about this take is that mob
justice
is not justice hours later after this
comment was made on cnn two police
officers were
shot this is not justice this has
nothing to do
with politics it has everything to do
with the value of human life
okay she is right about that of course
but it doesn't matter people got very
very angry because they're saying that
well if we keep turning up the rhetoric
in the media how are we to blame for all
this these are the same people who have
suggested that trump's rhetoric is to
blame for everything bad that has ever
happened
in the history of mankind meanwhile the
rhetoric continues to rise
over at our networks cnn's bakari
sellers said yesterday black lives
obviously don't matter in america
which is a weird take considering that
again
15 black americans were shot unarmed by
the police
all of last year 15. there are 42
million black people who live in america
black americans have been presidents of
the united states they've been attorney
general of the united states a black
american is running for vice presidents
of the united states we have black
supreme court justices
the leaders of our entertainment
industry many of them are black the
leaders of our sports industry nearly
all of them are black
at least in terms of the most public
faces but apparently black lives don't
matter in a country with the most
prominent black people on planet earth
by far here's bakari sellers
i think it's pretty clear that the black
lives do not matter
i think it's pretty clear that justice
is fleeting
that if you are a person of color
particularly a black woman in this
country
you know the quest for justice and the
road to get justice is longer and harder
than than most you know being black is a
perpetual state of grieving in this
country
and here we are again i've come on this
show and poured my heart out i've i've
you know cried i've laughed to prevent
myself from crying
it just hurts sometimes and here we are
again at another moment
being black in america is not a
perpetual state of grieving grieving in
america
means that you're grieving race does not
decide whether you grieve in a system
that does not discriminate against you
the brianna taylor case is not a syria
it is not a case of discrimination there
has yet to be an allegation that these
officers are racist
i mean again it is amazing how we
immediately jump to racism and no
supporting evidence needs to be
presented
at any point along the way we still by
the way don't have evidence that the
george floyd death was racist
let alone the brianna taylor death we
have no evidence
that virtually any of these cases have
anything to do with race
the the only case i can think of in the
past year that
there was some evidence presented for
the actual thesis that racism was
involved with the abundant case where
the guy's getting tried for first degree
murder
so i i'm wondering exactly why it is
that we are supposed to believe that
bukhari sellers who gets paid to be on
cnn
every day and spout this sort of
nonsense is in a perpetual state of
grieving over his race
that is not the country that people in
america are are now occupying we are not
living in 1960 we are not living in 1860
we are living in 2020.
i mean this is just by the way the the
attempt now to undermine the justice
system completely
is pace it's not just mob rule it's not
just we demand
indictments and charges brought against
people without evidence it's also that
we want to go after members of grand
juries who don't do what we want we'll
get to that in just one second
first you know how strongly i believe in
individual liberty and personal
responsibility
our founding fathers knew that these
were the cornerstones of a great
civilization which is why they created
the second amendment to secure every
american's fundamental human rights to
protect themselves
their family and their community and
owning a gun is a massive responsibility
it should work you should know how to
use it
this is why i really love our friends
over at bravo company manufacturing
they build rifles and those rifles are
built specifically to defend yourself
and your rights the people of bravo
company mfg support the right of
responsible private individuals to have
the access and ability to employ the
same tools as civilian law enforcement
as a means of defending ourselves our
loved ones
our communities and our freedoms should
a threatening situation god forbid ever
arise bcm assumes that when a rifle
leaves their shop it will be used in a
life or death situation by a responsible
citizen a law enforcement officer
or a soldier overseas so quality is of
utmost value to them every component of
a bcm rifle is hand assembled and tested
by americans i own two guns i have a
shotgun i have a handgun and i
fully intend on getting a rifle from my
friends at bravo company mfg i don't own
those guns to go hunting or target
shooting i own them because i want to be
able to protect myself and got in case
god forbid
somebody attempts to harm me or my
family bcm agrees to learn more about
bravo company manufacturing head on over
to bravocompanymfg.com where you can
discover more about their products
special offers in upcoming news that's
bravo company mfg.com
if you need more convincing find out
even more about bcm and the amazing
people who make their products at
youtube.com
bravo company usa go check them out
right now
okay so it is not enough apparently to
suggest without evidence
that this entire brianna taylor
situation is indicative of deeper
american racism we now
have calls to release grand jury
decision making now typically
to take for example federal grand juries
there's a reason that we do not release
grand jury
decision making information the reason
is if a grand jury is deciding whether
or not to indict somebody
what you don't want is they make a
decision not to indict and then
all the information is spilled into the
public eye and the person
is basically smeared with that
information for the rest of their life
right this is typically why you don't
release grand jury information
in the same way that let's say that the
police or prosecutors look into you and
then they decide not to prosecute
we don't just put those files online for
anybody to see because you didn't commit
a crime and frankly it's nobody's
business
you do have a right against not only
unreasonable search and seizure but
against being smeared
by the public authorities if you are not
going to be tried for a crime well in
this particular case these particular
officers are not being tried
and that means that grand jury
proceedings testimony they're in
revealing who on the go who was on the
grand jury right all of this is a very
very bad idea
nonetheless this is exactly what some
people are calling for benjamin crump
the attorney for the taylor family he's
the attorney for all of these families
and by the way a person who lies a lot
okay benjamin crump is a dishonest human
being
he lied about the facts of the case in
the michael brown shooting he lied about
the facts of the case with george floyd
he has lied about the facts of the case
repeatedly in a variety of these cases
well now benjamin crump is on tv
suggesting that they should release all
the transcripts of the grand jury
investigation saying quote if you did
everything you could do
on briana's behalf you shouldn't have
any problem whatsoever
he said that the the very fact that the
officers were not charged with some
degree of murder
means there seems to be two justice
systems in america one for black america
and one for white america
this is such nonsense it's such nonsense
and then he implied that the attorney
general of kentucky a black man daniel
cameron
decided that he was going to exonerate
these officers against the evidence he
said did he present any evidence on
brianna taylor's behalf or did he make a
unilateral decision to put his thumb on
the scales of justice
wait a second any evidence on brianna
she wasn't on trial he doesn't have to
present evidence quote on behalf of the
victim
the question is whether the officers
committed a crime that doesn't even make
any legal sense
i mean krump of course was tweeting out
uh the
the say her name stuff and suggesting
that brianna taylor's name was not
mentioned in the indictment
right because the crime was not the
shooting of brianna taylor she was shot
by accident
that's a tragedy again it is not a crime
and then
krump said it follows a pattern of the
blatant disrespect and marginalization
of black people but especially black
women in america
have been killed by police so i have a
question i have a question for benjamin
crump benjamin crump also happens to be
the attorney for the jacob lake family
jacob blake was shot after the police
were called to the site
of a situation where a woman who had
alleged rape
digital rape against jacob blake called
the cops because blake showed up again
a few months earlier she had called the
cops because jacob blake according to
her
had digitally penetrated her against her
will with a child in the room
jacob lake then showed up at her house
the cops showed up he resisted arrest he
resisted a tase he apparently got an
officer in a headlock
he then ignored the officer's orders to
stop he walked around to the front side
of the car they found a knife on the
floorboards of the driver's side of the
car
benjamin crump suggested that jacob
blake was there to break up a fight
between two women
there was no evidence for this at all
none okay was that respect
for black women that's a serious
question for ben crump
is that respect for black women because
it seems to me like if you wanted to
respect a black woman one thing you
might do
is believe her after she repeatedly
asserts that a man digitally raped her
instead of you know defending the guy
who digitally raped her and suggesting
wrongly that he was there as some sort
of as some sort of good samaritan
breaking up a fight
but the facts don't matter again as
always the facts don't matter this tears
apart the country
it destroys the country when you are so
concerned with the narrative that
america is evil
that you decide to ignore the underlying
facts it tears apart the country and
honestly it's being done
on purpose it's being done on purpose
now meanwhile
speaking of tearing apart the country we
have seen an incredible news cycle
in which the media are now alleging that
donald trump is going to hole up in the
white house
like al pacino at the end of scar
scarface and snort coke
in giant lines from a table and then
fire a submachine gun say
say hello to my say hello to my little
friend come on in
say that's not how it's going to go
you're all idiots
everybody knows this is idiotic this is
again the media spinning their wheels in
an attempt to justify
any and all action against the trump
administration or any and all
preparations up to and including
maybe violent protest and looting since
they've been so in favor of it in past
few months
in the aftermath of the election if
there's any confusion at all
which unfortunately thanks to everything
going on there's probably bound to be
we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about a
better way of watching
tv okay so the fact is you're probably
if you have cable you're paying too much
like
way way way too much for your cable and
you're getting a bunch of channels
you don't even want there is a better
way to do this instead
you should be checking out fubo tv you
can get everything you want all in one
place for less than the cost of cable
fubo tv will bring you over 100 channels
cloud tvr no hidden fees you can stream
shows on your tv or any other smart
device as well we've got the major
broadcast and cable networks you can
find all your shows including live
sports
news primetime tv of course they have
fox news with fubotv you get all your
favorites you get this is us and the
bachelor you get the premier league and
the nba which when it stops being
political you'll watch again
all the news channels so much more
there's no risk to try it out get full
access to fubotv for seven days for free
like go give it a try
you know a few years before streaming
was ubiquitous maybe keeping the cable
made sense but everybody
that i know has cut the quarter i got i
cut the cord like solidly 10 years ago
you should cut the cord down you're
paying way too much for your cable and
especially if you can get the same
product
without the cable right now fubo tv is
offering our listeners the seven day
free trial and
15 off your first month by going to
fubotv.com are no contracts you can
cancel anytime
head on over to fubotv.com for 15 off
your first month and a free trial that's
fubotv.comfubotv.com
go check them out right now alrighty
we're going to get back into this um
this latest
furor over the supposed willingness of
president trump
to engage in a coup okay honest to god
the the president does not have the
capacity to
plan beyond his next tweet but he's
apparently planning a deep
and effective coup mm-hmm yeah say the
people who have refused to
accept the results of the 2016 election
so much so that they literally
militarized the fbi in order to go after
the trump administration and went after
michael flynn and then for several years
touted the idea that the russians had
stolen the election
in cahoots with the trump administration
yes these are the people i trust when it
comes to
being very anti-coup mm-hmm okay in just
a second we'll get to more of this
first you don't want to miss another
great episode of the sunday special
coming up this weekend
former trump administration press
secretary sarah huckabee sanders comes
on the show to discuss her time working
for the president
her best and worst days as press
secretary which reporters are the worst
off camera i think you probably know the
answers and the real question
do we need more teleprompter trump
so go watch over at dailywire.com or
listen on apple podcast spotify
wherever else you get your podcast take
a look at this amazing trailer
were in japan walking into a bilateral
meeting with prime minister abe
and the president who has every reason
to be focused on the meeting in front of
him
and not concerned about you know my
feelings or where i am
stops and says hold on he turns he looks
me straight in the eye and he said sarah
the only reason they come after you is
because you're good at your job
one of the things i love about doing the
sunday special is the wide variety of
guests i don't know if there's any other
show
where one week you'll get mad iglesias
from box and the next week you'll get
sarah huckabee sanders it's it's
definitely
a lot of fun we have an eclectic group
of guests this year scheduled for the
season so go check that out as part of
our daily wire audience by the way there
are a number of ways you can take in the
podcast you can listen on apple podcast
spotify or another podcast app
you can also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook or over at
dailywire.com here's the bottom line
we're making our content available to
you anywhere you watch or listen
dailywire members can now enjoy our
shows on apple tv and roku so members
can enjoy all the visual elements of
this podcast and our other shows on your
big screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wire on apple tv or roku
download it today you have to be an
insider member to watch live head on
over to dailywire.com
shapiro use code watch at checkout to
get 15
off your membership purchase the deal's
not gonna last long act fast if you want
live shows on your big screen plus
the one of a kind highly coveted often
imitated
never duplicated makes julianne fry's
leftist years tumblr again that is
dailywire.com
shapiro to get 15 off with codewatch
download the daily wire on your apple tv
and roku today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so we are in the midst of a of a
completely
generated news cycle okay it's a news
cycle spun up
out of nothing trump was having a very
good week he had the supreme court
nomination
on his hands politically speaking he had
the the democrats once again
providing tacit support to rioters and
looters as per their usual arrangement
like this was a pretty solid political
week for trump leading into the debates
and then trump stepped in it right he
was asked a specific question
about whether win lose or draw which is
a weird way to word it win lose or draw
would he concede the results of the
election and and
exceed to a peaceful transfer of power
if he lost was basically the idea
and he he misdirected he essentially
said i'll keep all my options open
because there might be fraud and the
media immediately took this to me he's
gonna coo it
he's gonna he's gonna hold up he's gonna
put a big padlock like a bike lock
on the front door of the white house and
then he's gonna stay inside
he's gonna pee in jars like howard
hughes and that's gonna be the new white
house and we're gonna have to bust down
the door
i mean this is all their fever dream
fantasies right there's all the things
they want to happen
because they've always wanted to see
trump frog marched out of the white
house so that that's like their dream
is is the navy seals rappelling in
through the top
of the white house to capture president
trump like white house down or something
this is what they have been fevered
masturbatorily thinking about
for for years right they hate trump this
much and trump stepped in it because
that's what trump does if there's a pile
of poop the president
has an uncanny ability to step in every
pile of poop if you let him loose
in a in a on a polo ground he would find
every
horse dropping and put his foot directly
in it this is just his special gift i
know some people think
that this is all planned it is not
planned okay it is not planned
this is not me saying that the president
is a complete adult it is me saying he
has an uncanny ability to jump on every
rake with both feet so he jumped on that
rake
and the media and the media immediately
spun it up now what are they really
doing why are the media doing this
okay for two reasons one there's a
report that come out that came out
several weeks ago
now in which the media reported that
democrats were preparing all sorts
of post-election noise and chaos
that all these liberal progressive
groups had gotten together and they were
planning not only protests in the
streets but they were they were trying
to figure out you know
how rabid would they have to get what
sort of measures would they have to take
in order to prevent trump from stealing
the white house see the thing is
that if you if you generate a narrative
the trump's going to steal the white
house you have to take preventative
measures of course
and we saw stories a month ago that john
podesta part of the biden campaign
war gamed out what it would look like if
biden refused to concede
in in case of a close election and that
included things like
cal the state of california seceding
from the union not kidding
okay so they've been trying this for a
while they're trying to legitimize every
plan they have for the dissolution of
the union and or for the violation of
law
and all they need is the slightest
indicator from trump that maybe that's a
real possibility
and so that is that is point number one
point number two is they're trying to
drive trump off of his generalized point
which is
if there are questionable practices in
the election then
he should immediately ignore the
questionable practices in the election
and just concede the election
and that's gonna be particularly true
this year like what they want
is for trump to concede as fast as
humanly possible or if trump spots
evidence that bad stuff is happening for
him to ignore that so we can all move on
with our lives with the democratic
president
right that is that is the goal here now
trump for his part has suggested
that there is the possibility of voter
fraud in mail-in voting there is that
possibility
how broad that possibility is has yet to
be discovered there is not a lot of data
to suggest
widespread voter fraud meaning like tens
of thousands of ballots which it would
take to swing some of these states for
example
or hundreds of thousands of ballots
nationally and the president has
suggested repeatedly
that there might be some sort of
screwing around
with the balloting process which again
is bad news democrats have been doing
this too by the way so this is not
unique to one side of the aisle or the
other
all of this undermines faith in the
elections but it's only bad when trump
does it according to the left because
they expect that biden is going to win
now this is getting really complicated
because the democrats made a very large
strategic error here which was
in the middle of the pandemic they said
to all of their voters we want you to
vote early
right we want you to get your mail-in
ballot we want you to vote early the
problem is
and balloting is actually a lot harder
than going to the polling place you go
to the polling place
out here in california anyway as long as
i have been voting
they have not digital voting they have
the actual
the actual paper ballots and you punch
out the chads and they have
kind of a system by which you can ensure
that the chads have actually fallen out
so you don't end up with like the
pregnant chad problem that you had
in 2000 in florida in miami-dade county
and palm beach county
so voting in person is actually a lot
easier than voting by mail
voting by mail you get the ballot then
you have to fill in one envelope then
you put it in a second envelope and a
third envelope you have to
it's in some areas take it to a specific
mailbox it gets very complicated
democrats realize that they were
shooting themselves in the foot by
basically telling everybody not to go to
the polling places so now they've
reversed themselves and they're like
everybody should go vote
in person but what they're afraid of is
that on election day it's gonna look
like trump won
because everybody who votes in person is
gonna be a republican and everybody who
votes by mail is gonna be a democrat
conversely by the way donald trump
suddenly realized about two months ago
that it was a mistake to tell elderly
people in florida who are the most
likely people not to go to the polls
to not vote by mail he was like you know
what every place else every place else
voting by mail's bad florida's good
right i mean it's very obvious
and transparently political what is
happening right now
but the media's narrative here is that
no matter what happens trump should
concede
if trump looks like he has won he should
concede if trump looks like he has lost
he should concede the only situation in
which trump should not concede
presumably
is one in which it looks like he has won
the popular vote which is of course the
most unlikely of all scenarios
considering he lost the popular vote by
two and a half million
last time so president trump was asked
about it again yesterday are you going
to concede
if it's a close election are you going
to accept defeat will there be a
peaceful transfer of power now the
normal answer to this question
is of course once all of the information
is in and the election has been decided
there will be a peaceful transfer of
power
that's the obvious answer but president
trump goes another direction
he points out correctly that hillary
clinton has said that she would tell
biden never to concede
we want to make sure the election is
honest and i'm not sure that it can be i
don't
i don't know that it can be with this
whole
situation unsolicited ballots they're
unsolicited millions being sent to
everybody and
we'll see but if you remember hillary
clinton just a week ago or so
told joe biden do not accept the results
of the election
under any circumstances but you don't
ask her that question you only ask me
the question
okay he is right did they never ask joe
biden the question is whether he will
concede the election
and there will be a peaceful transfer of
power of course biden doesn't step on
that rig particularly like he'll be a
little bit more fluid with that but it's
perfectly obvious there will be a
peaceful transfer of power mitch
mcconnell the senate majority leader
was asked about this and he was like of
course there will be an orderly
transition he tweeted out
the winner of the november third
election will be inaugurated on january
20th
there will be an orderly transition just
as there has been every four years since
1792.
yes duh that of course is true the media
of course ignored that and so you end up
with chuck schumer on the house
on the senate floor ranting against
republicans the republicans
are preparing to militarize in defense
of president trump's seizing power or
something here's chuck schumer being
utterly
and and obviously and consistently
dishonest as for our usual arrangement
where are our republican colleagues this
is not a partisan issue
democracy is at stake and every
constituent
from every corner of the land regardless
of party or ideology should be asking
their republican senators to speak out
and demand that donald trump
not be allowed to do what he says he's
going to do and say they will join
all of america in standing in the way
if he tries no one believes he's even
going to try this it is perfectly
obvious he's not going to try this i
mean come on
come on everybody knows that there will
be a peaceful transition of power
kaylee mcinning the white house press
secretary she says of course trump's
going to accept the results if he loses
he's going to leave and if he wins he's
going to stay like this is so stupid
here's kaylee mcinning yesterday
the president will accept the results of
a free and fair election
uh but i think that your question is
more fitting to be asked of democrats
who have already been on the record
saying they won't accept the results of
an election
um in fact i have several of them here
for you south carolina democrat
uh jim clyburn has said uh that trump is
not going to win fairly
and then you have uh that beautiful
quote from hillary clinton clinton that
joe biden should not concede under any
circumstance so
i think your fitting is more question
more uh fitting question for democrats
of course that is exactly right but the
media have generated a narrative because
again
the goal here is that if there's any
confusion in the election trump should
concede preemptively
and also that if there is chaos after
the election it's justified
by trumpian rhetoric which has been
their consistent position for quite a
while now meanwhile
there was a story yesterday that the fbi
is investigating at least nine discarded
military million ballots
in pennsylvania apparently online were
marked for donald trump the fbi
announced on thursday it was
investigating issues with mail-in
ballots in pennsylvania's lucerne county
after recovering at least nine votes
that had been improperly
discarded since monday fbi personnel
working together with pennsylvania state
police
have conducted numerous interviews and
recovered and reviewed certain physical
evidence said the doj
at this point we can confirm a small
number of military ballots were
discarded
investigators have recovered nine
ballots at this time some of these
ballots can be attributed to specific
voters some cannot
pennsylvania has faced controversy over
its mail-in voting process because of
the issue of naked ballots meaning
ballots that are not inserted into a
second
secrecy envelope the pennsylvania
supreme court ruled friday officials
could reject ballots that do not
arrive in the second envelope which is
aimed at preventing them from seeing how
ballots are filled out
state election officials previously
issued guidance telling counties to
count the ballots
now the problem of course is that you
want to make sure that people can't
actually just look through the envelope
see who you voted for and then just toss
the ballot pennsylvania is one of 16
states that provides such envelopes
philadelphia city commission chair lisa
dealey warned in a letter monday
the issue could result in as many as 100
000 votes being lost
the fbi did not say whether it was
related to the ballots discarded in
lucerne county
trump won pennsylvania by just 44 000
votes in 2016 and he won luzerne county
by
26 237 votes out of the more than 130
cast apparently two of the discarded
ballots had been resealed inside their
appropriate envelopes by loser and
election staff prior to recovery
by the con by the fbi the seven were for
trump
so again couple points one it's nine
ballots
so that's not a ton of ballots two is
there potential for a serious
fraud here yeah there is so this is the
real question and this is the problem
so christopher wray the head of the fbi
says listen there's been no evidence of
massive voter fraud thus far this is
correct there has been no evidence of
massive voter fraud thus far
we take all election related threats
seriously whether it's
voter fraud voter suppression whether
it's in person whether it's by mail and
our role is to investigate the threat
actors
now we have not seen historically
any kind of coordinated national voter
fraud effort
in a major election whether it's by mail
or
or otherwise we have seen voter fraud uh
at the local level from time to time
okay so he is he's correct about this
that doesn't mean there's not the
potential for serious voter fraud
uh faith in elections is an all-time low
at a time when americans are more
divided than ever so all of that is of
course
bad news okay meanwhile the president
this weekend probably tomorrow is going
to announce his supreme court pick
there are two possibilities that are
seen as sort of above and beyond
everybody else one is barbara lagoa who
is in 11th circuit court of appeals
judge in florida she's of cuban
extraction
and her record for what it is is solid
she has expressed tremendous support for
originalism
she is should be a solid pick amy coney
barrett of course is the other on the
seventh circuit court of appeals she's
already been preemptively targeted
by democrats who continue to maintain
that catholicism is some sort of barrier
to serving in the in the government
which is hilarious i mean really really
funny considering that pelosi herself is
a catholic
and joe biden is a catholic so i i have
a question i guess the way they mean
this is that if you're an actual
catholic meaning you you follow the
doctrines
and and you follow the latest papal
encyclicals and and you follow
all of the rules and procedures of
catholicism and actually take the views
of the catholic church seriously
then you can't be in the government so
the only way you can be in the
government to be a catholic
is if you are sort of a tea time
catholic right you only go to church
once every so often you kind of mouth
the platitudes you say if you
you say little mumbo jumbo in latin and
then you go vote for abortion on demand
and then you can be in government so in
other words you can't really hold
catholic values
also if you hold catholic values that
inevitably is going to infuse
your practice of the legal profession so
you have no capacity to separate off
from your own personal convictions on
the death penalty for example
you instead are going to just vote
against the application of the death
penalty in every case because you're a
catholic
you have no capacity to actually enforce
the law now all of this is nonsense
but unfortunately democrats are
promoting it nancy pelosi yesterday
was asked about essentially a religious
test for the court and she refused to
say whether religion
should be a barrier to being on the
court
article 6 which bans religious texts
from being a qualification for
office do you think that that should
apply to supreme court nominees as well
i'm not going to get into anybody's
interpretation of one thing or another
the confirmation is the work of the
senate and i
trust the judgment of our democrats
okay so that's a no yes and no she's not
going to rule out a religious test
for the supreme court of the united
states for her part dianne feinstein is
acknowledging full out that she just
does not have the power to block any of
trump's nominees
according to usa today she said neither
this committee nor the senate should
consider a nomination at this time
i recognize i don't have the power to
carry that through but i feel it very
deeply
and because at least dianne feinstein's
been in the senate long enough to
understand how the procedures work this
of course has led the democrats i'm not
kidding you
to charge that she should be removed
from the senate judiciary committee
because she is old and daughtering
not a joke they're running joe biden who
is old and doddering and has declared a
lid
every day for the last seven years and
dianne feinstein is now
not sufficiently with it to lead up the
senate judiciary committee
because she points out quite obviously
that the democrats just don't have the
votes
in the senate meanwhile things uh you
know are at a high pitch in this country
i think it's fair to say so president
trump and melania trump
visited the rbg memorial she uh she was
lying in state apparently it's okay to
have giant crowds as long as they're
paying tribute to rbg or protesting
racial justice in any case
trump and melania went to visit the rbg
memorial over at the supreme court
and probably were greeted by what sounds
like ghouls shrieking from hell
that is that is all i mean that's what
it sounds like i can't confirm that
that's actually what it was but that is
exactly what it sounds like they were
screaming
at trump for the great sin of visit of
paying some sort of homage to rbg
[Applause]
sounds like the sold in the damned
shrieking up from the hell and trump
my goodness that is solid stuff right
there making a difference by the way
making difference in the middle of
pandemic
shouting at trump
and then chanting vote him out
okay so good times right there and
how crazy have some people gone there
was an editorial that was making its way
around the internet yesterday from a
person named jamie smith
here's the title of the editorial from
huffington post the death of justice
ruth bader ginsburg
pushed me to join the satanic temple i
mean
fair enough i'm a 40-something attorney
and mother who lives in a quiet
neighborhood with a yard and a garage
full of scooters and soccer balls
i'm not the type of person who would
normally consider becoming a satanist
but these
are not normal times you might want to
consider your life choices
if your politics have now driven you to
become a satanist
like so many other women in the united
states it says this idiot columnist for
the huffington post
when i learned of justice ruth better
ginsburg's passing my first reaction was
not grief but fear
i fear that americans are inching closer
to living in a theocracy or dictatorship
and the checks meant to prevent this
from happening are close to eroding
beyond repair now again
even if roe vs wade were overturned
tomorrow abortion is not going to be
outlawed
in california okay that is not the way
any of this works but doesn't matter
we got to pretend that we are on the
verge of theocracy we're on the verge of
the handmaid's tale
members of the satanic temple do not
believe in the supernatural or
superstition which is weird because they
call themselves members of the satanic
temple
in the same way that some unitarians and
some jews do not believe in god satanic
temple members do not worship satan and
both
most are atheists they are not
affiliated in any way with the church of
satan
instead the satanic temple uses the
devil as a symbol of rebellion
again if you are using you know the
symbol of
pure evil in order to s in order to show
that you are rebelling against the
system
i don't think that you are a good person
according to this columnist when justice
ginsburg died i knew immediately action
was needed on a scale we've not seen
before our democracy has become so
fragile the loss of one of the last
guardians of common sense and decency
and government
less than two months before a pivotal
election has put our civil
and reproductive rights in danger like
never before and so i
have turned to satanism yeah that seems
like the rational decision
you didn't go out and buy a protest sign
or register somebody to vote
you when you join satan why the hell not
i mean just
live your creed man i mean for for
abortion on demand i kind of see it
like other faiths the satanic temple has
a code that members believe
in deeply and used to guide their lives
these seven fundamental tenets include
that one should strive to act with
compassion and empathy toward all
creatures in accordance with reason
and that the struggle for justice is an
ongoing and necessary pursuit that
should prevail
over laws and institutions and the one's
body is inviolable subject to one's will
alone unless you're sticking a scalpel
into like the head of an unborn fetus
that kid's body doesn't matter
at all also i do love the struggle for
justice is an ongoing necessary pursuit
that should prevail
over laws and institutions as the laws
and institutions
are not in many cases founded on justice
they're not always founded on just in
many cases they are
so this lady became a satanist that that
seems like a good solution rbg dies so
uh you go to
a satanic temple i have joined a
community who will stop at nothing to
safeguard my family's rights and all of
our rights when they are at their most
vulnerable jamie smith is an attorney
and mother who cares about civil rights
and also
worships satan but not really because
they just they're just facetious about
it you see
yes we may have all lost our minds okay
meanwhile
kovan 19 updates so we are seeing a
surge in some states in
covid 19. we're seeing a sort of second
wave happening in more rural areas of
arizona
there are some 22 states that have seen
an uptick in
coronavirus in the recent past none of
them are on the verge
of being overwhelmed the hospital system
is not being overwhelmed in any of these
states
we've seen a flattening out in in many
of the biggest states
right florida georgia these are states
where you've seen a flattening out in
the number of active cases and in fact
you're on the other side of active cases
in florida the bell curve is already
coming down the other side
the daily deaths tend to you know lag a
fair bit
with that said i've got bad news and
i've got good news
so the the bad news is that according to
jackie cello reporting from the new york
post
a new covet 19 mutation appears to be
even more contagious according to a
study
experts say it could be a response by
the virus to defeat masks and other
social distancing efforts
scientists in a paper published
wednesday identified a new strand of the
virus
which accounted for 99.9 percent of
cases during the second wave in the
houston texas area
the paper which has not been
peer-reviewed said people with this
strain
known as the d614g mutation had higher
loads of virus suggesting it is more
contagious
though the strain isn't more deadly
researchers said it appeared to have
adapted better to spread among humans
he said it's possible david moran's
virologist at the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases said it's possible
that the virus had now evolved
to resist efforts like hand washing and
social distancing
morin said wearing masks washing our
hands all those things are barriers to
transmissibility or contagion but as the
virus becomes more contagious it
statistically
is better at getting around those
barriers in other bad news by the way
the vaccination effort will not be
complete until july according to the cdc
director
robert redfield told the senate health
and education committee in a wednesday
hearing
that it would take us until april may
june maybe july
to get the entire american public
completely vaccinated so that means
middle of
next year at best as we say
you know we've seen spikes around the
country now we are not seeing the deaths
follow yet
the the the death rates in europe remain
actually extremely low
despite massive increases in the number
of cases and it's important to note here
that the massive increases in numbers of
cases are not happening under trump's
watch okay this is not rhonda santa's
this is happening in france it is
happening in israel it is happening in
great britain
we're seeing massive spikes around
europe right now
in fact in israel they've basically
declared martial law i mean because yom
kippur is coming up which is a time when
people go to
synagogue and they tend to pray they
have like a big controversy over in
israel because the left
wants people to be allowed to protest in
certain numbers and the right wants
people to be able to pray in certain
numbers and the government is trying to
shut down
everything daily cases in israel have
spiked
to nearly 7 000 apparently meanwhile
record infections in france
and restrictions have sparked an outcry
there too so people are protesting
restrictions there as well
figures from the public health france
showed that 16 096 people had tested
positive for covid
over the last 24 hours which is a record
even though experts advise the testing
during the first coronavirus wave in
march and april captured only a fraction
of the cases
the centrist government of president
emmanuel macron announced a series of
new measures on wednesday
to try to slow the spread of the disease
including the closure of all bars and
restaurants in marseille
and earlier closing times in paris and
elsewhere
prime minister john castax called for
responsibility and implied his opponents
were playing politics
he said what i don't want is that we go
back to march which is referring to
the strict national lockdown that was
used by the french government
marseille has now been put on maximum
alert paris and 10 other cities have put
on
been put on elevated alert as well
the question is how long the
hospitalizations are going to lag
according to the new york times
the the cases that are upticking in
spain and france and the uk
means that more people are are now being
restricted to their homes
boris johnson and other european leaders
according to the new york times are
dealing with a confusing fast-changing
situation with conflicting evidence on
how quickly
new cases are translating into hospital
admissions and how severe those cases
will end up being
in spain where new cases have surged to
more than 10 000 a day
hospitals in madrid are close to
capacity the government said it is
preparing to open field hospitals in
hotels and in the city's largest
exhibition center but in france which
reported 66 000 new cases over the last
seven days
hospital admissions and deaths they're
rising but they're going up much more
slowly
there's also a divergence between
infection rates and hospitalizations in
germany and austria
in britain which reported over six
thousand new coveted cases on wednesday
just 134 patients were admitted to
hospitals that's barely a tenth of those
admitted
in early may some experts argue this
shows the virus has lost potency or that
it is now infecting mostly younger
people
others say it's a testament to social
distancing and face masks see the
problem is
that the social distancing phase face
mask thesis
is really kind of unprovable
because in certain places like northern
europe they're doing social distancing
but not face masks and they have not
seen
this massive uptick in death by the way
sweden has seen no uptick in in caseload
or death because they already got hit
norway is seeing a pretty significant
uptick in caseload
and but not death indiana for what it's
worth is now moving toward total
reopening
according to the indianapolis star
nearly three months after suspending
indiana's reopening plan governor eric
holcomb on wednesday announced the state
will move to the final phase
phase stage five as the statewide mass
order remains in place indefinitely that
means restaurants bars fitness centers
and stores
will now be able to operate at full
capacity but people will be expected to
main social distance in these places and
keep their masks on
except while eating and drinking holcomb
led with the reopening which is good
news to some then followed up with the
continuation of the mask order
he acknowledged that his preference
would be not to wear face coverings but
doing so is essential to allowing the
state to
move toward reopening and this seems
correct the only people who really
should not be masking at this point are
small children
who apparently are not spreading this
thing in major numbers k-12 schools
across
the world have been avoiding coveted
surges thus far
according to michael osterholm director
of the center for infectious
disease research and policy at the
university of minnesota he said everyone
had a fear there would be explosive
outbreaks of transmission in schools in
colleges there have been
we we have to say that to date we have
not seen this in younger kids that
really is an important observation by
the way there's a good case to be made
that at colleges you should basically
just shut the colleges to the outside
and let the kids basically go about
their daily lives and if infections
spread at colleges
the number of 20 year olds who are going
to die from covet is very low and then
they can't be
pathways for transmission meanwhile
nancy pelosi has abruptly shifted her
course and started pushing
relief after shutting it down for
several months on end
quick note on this you know so anthony
fatchi there's a wildly publicized
exchange between anthony fauci and
senator rand paul a little bit earlier
this week
and i didn't have a chance to comment on
it on the podcast and so i would like to
now here was dr fauci versus rand paul
it turns out that fauci is just not
right on some of this stuff
they've developed enough community
immunity that they're no longer having
the pandemic because they have enough
immunity in new york city to actually
stop
i challenge that uh senator because
i want to please sir i would like to be
able to do this because this happens
with senator and all the time
you were not listening to what the
director of the cdc said
that in new york it's about 22 if you
believe
22 is hurt immunity i believe you're
alone
in that okay well nobody has suggested
that herd immunity kicks in at 20
what people have suggested correctly is
that there is something called t cell
immunity and resistance
and that means the people who have
pre-existing
sort of immune response to covid because
they had a cold a couple of years ago
they have a bit of a coronavirus
response mechanism already in place that
they're not they're not getting as
serious forms of the disease anywhere
from 20 to 50 percent of the population
may already have that
you can't just add 20 fully immune to 20
to 50
partially immune what you can suggest is
that
the vast majority of the population is
not extraordinarily susceptible to covet
but this has been true for a long time
the vast majority of the population is
not extraordinarily susceptible
to covet and by extraordinarily
susceptible i don't mean that this thing
is
is not is on the part with the flu it
isn't it's much more deadly than the flu
what i mean is that the actual numbers
of people who die after obtaining covid
is not fifty percent it is not ten
percent it is not five percent the
actual number of people
who die after obtaining covid is
something on average
like maybe five in one thousand and not
five and a hundred five and one thousand
which is bad that's not great i mean
that's the average rate of death after
you obtain covet right point
for the flu it's one in one thousand but
here is a dr scott atlas kind of
debunking what fauci says right there
the reality is that according to the
papers from sweden
singapore and elsewhere there is
cross-immunity
highly likely from other infections and
there is also t-cell immunity and the
combination of those
makes the antibodies a small fraction of
the people that have immunity so the
answer is no
it is not 90 of people that are
susceptible to the infection so i guess
my question is for i'm not a doctor i
defer to your expertise on this
end to his but so americans hear one
thing from the cdc director and another
thing from you
who are we to believe you're supposed to
believe the science and i'm telling you
the science
okay alice happens to be correct about
this fauci said there's no study he
actually he actually said there's like
one study that says that t-cell immunity
isn't a thing there are probably 25
studies that say t-cell immunity is a
thing
okay so what is the good news what is
the bad news the the only good news here
really is that people are recognizing
sooner rather than later that we're
going to have to learn to live with the
virus and what that means europe has
said this
many republican governors have been
saying this i've been saying this for a
long time that means if you are younger
and healthier you should be going back
to work
it means you should be wearing a mask
and you should socially distance when
possible
that's all and if you are uniquely
vulnerable if you are elderly then you
should stay
out of the way and if you know one of
those people you should stay out of
their way
that's it that's all we know all right
so this weekend president trump will
make his skoda's pick
i'm not going to be here monday so i
won't be here to comment on it because
it's yom kippur so i'll be doing some
repenting
i feel like i have some things to repent
for this this year so i will be doing
that on monday but we'll be back here on
tuesday the debate happens tuesday a lot
coming up
try not to burn things down while i'm
gone please for the love of pete
you're listening to the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen
you